Hey, guys. It's me Issa Rae,
and I am joined
by our incredibly talented
showrunner, Prentice Penny,
for another season
of our Wine Down.
♪ (UPTEMPO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
So, the cold open ends
with Issa saying
she doesn't "eff" with Molly
no more.
How does this set the tone
for the new season?
We've been building
to Issa and Molly needing
to have a conversation.
And we want the audience
to be like,
"What-- What did I miss?"
Our show is known as--
you know,
for Issa
and Molly's relationship,
they are legit friends.
They're girls.
They ride for each other.
We wanted to start to question:
"Are these friendships
or relationships for a reason,
or for a season?"
So, one of the things
that's a big deal
is how everybody's like
leveling up this year.
Well, Issa and Molly start off
as we see them, together, uh,
-taking care of themselves.
-Yep.
And I think Issa,
more so than Molly,
has decided to focus
on nothing but good vibes.
Making sure that her career
or her passion is in order.
And not letting distractions,
uh, take her away from that.
I think also too,
like what we've done, too,
is I think tried to flip
the season a little bit.
The dynamics where like,
"Oh, Issa has a lot of work--
-Yeah.
-...situations,
and Molly is having
more personal, men issues."
They've tasked each other
to hold each other accountable.
And we found out at the end
of the episode that...
-(WINCES)
-...maybe Issa's not ready
for Molly to hold her
so accountable,
and to be so truthful.
Um...
It's almost like, uh,
be careful what you wish for.
Yeah. So,
throughout the series,
we haven't seen Molly
be in a long-term relation--
-No.
-Her relationships.
-She blows those up.
-Yeah! (CHUCKLES)
They kind of fizzle.
I think, inherently, her nature,
is to want to be boo'd up.
-I think she's fighting...
-Yeah.
...that energy
to want to do that.
And I think when she realizes,
like, "Oh, he's dating too."
Which is what you said
you were doing, it's like,
"I don't really want you
to be out there...
-Exactly.
-...I'm out there."
Despite her denial,
she's invested in Andrew--
-For sure. Yes
-...at this point.
And I think it was a big step
for her to text him.
-Yep.
-And...
I'm curious, like,
why do you think Molly comes
for Issa after finding out
that she's gonna
continue working
with Condola,
despite the fact that Condola
is dating Lawrence?
Molly, knowing Issa's history,
I think she knows more
about Issa
and Lawrence's relationship
-than anyone.
-Yeah.
Molly knows that Issa's
ultimately gonna be affected
-by this.
-Molly knows all this stuff
about you as a friend,
and Condola doesn't know
anything.
And Condola's energy
is just to want to build you up,
so that's infectious, right?
Like, you're already feeling
-like planning this is a lot.
-Yeah.
And here comes this woman
believing in you
while this other friend
is kind of like,
-"Girl, this is a mess."
-That is so real too.
And we've talked about this
in the room.
is that Issa is the type
of person
to feed off of people putting
that kind of energy in her.
Yep.
Like, she needs that
to kind of succeed.
In some ways you need
stupidity around you...
-(LAUGHS)
-...to-- Because--
Like the first person to fly,
he's going,
"I'ma do what that bird does."
-It's like, "Fool, don't."
-Yeah, "Don't."
"Don't, you ain't gonna fly."
-But that person next to you...
-But you need to believe--
...is like, "Yeah, bruh, fly."
-"You could fly!"
-"You could fly!" Like--
Why do you feel Issa
has the need
to tell these potential sponsors
different versions
of what the block party
should be?
(SIGHS) Issa's always
just trying to sell some shit.
It's just-- Honesty is not
her favorite policy.
Yeah.
And I think this comes
from this feeling of like,
"Maybe my event
isn't good enough.
Maybe I'm not the right person
to do this,
so I need to tell them
what they want to hear.
As opposed to having them buy in
to who I am,
because maybe who I am
isn't enough."
You know, in the end,
they bought into her.
Like when you're throwing
an event like this,
nobody's like, really like,
"Oh, this event
is the dopest thing,"
or, "This is the best idea."
-They're really looking at you.
-Yeah.
They're like,
"What is it about you
that I should put my money
behind?"
And I think she realizes that
later.
-This is a good season.
-It is gonna be good.
Thank you for hanging out
with us tonight.
See you next week.
-Next week, cheers.
-Cheers!
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪